that's why even Ben Stiller not
apologizing for Tropic Thunder like I
don't I don't have an issue with that
because I never looked at them as trying
to be black
what keep going I never thought they
were trying to be black and Tropic
Thunder I thought they just had Tans yes
and
I just is that black I thought blackface
is when you're pretending to be black
that's what the original Minstrel show
was doing in the movies
to look black and then he's acting black
I never saw Tropic Thunder
never saw it clipping
I've never seen Tropic I actually
thought it was Robert Downey Jr that had
that it was it was it was movie he
directed it and
[Music]
you're a genius bro
so he was pretending to be black we
gotta probably be a method actor let's
just watch it basically yeah the
characters like oh
can we can we go to the beginning
[__] oh go back now
handicap people y'all gotta get in on
this too now everybody knows you never
go full [__]
so yo I've never seen Tropic Thunder
I've never seen Robinson ever in my life
the band's still a character played a
character that was fully [__] oh
that guy right there was supposed to be
no in another movie okay like that's the
the movie's about the making of a movie
yeah and they're making fun of all these
Hollywood tropes really like how far
actors will go to like get into
character and take roles from people who
should actually play them so it makes
sense for Robert Downey Jr to be playing
a black man yes yeah but people are
still upset just because he is in Black
even though they're making fun of an
actor that would wear a blackface I I
you know I don't I don't you know but
Ben still is like I'm not gonna
apologize for a movie anymore why would
you apologize for a movie that was the
kind of movie that is supposed to be
it's like Bingo like no one makes Leo to
like apologize for saying that word it's
a period piece yeah well his tweet he
said I'd never apologize for making the
movie I think he apologized one time
because of the [__] stuff because Sean
White the snowboarder I think went oh it
has like a simple Jack character for
Halloween and then that was kind of
offensive so he just apologized was like
yo oh God no offense is Sean or whatever
I'll apologize whoever was offended but
he never apologized for the black face
or even really the playing of that
because it's that it's all making fun of
the industry not making fun of the
people the minorities it's making fun of
the industry it's making fun of actors
that would go this far to get an award
yeah yeah and then never go full [__]
thing is making fun of like we want to
see people who we think are mentally who
look mentally challenged but not really
like they would never hire an actual
autistic person to play those roles yeah
yeah I get it yeah but people are still
upset because they don't want to think
about the whole context of it and he
said someone said some guy tweeted him
like you need to stop apologizing for
this movie I loved it and then he
responded he's like I never apologize
for the movie I'm very proud of it and
just to be clear we were making fun of
the actors not the industry basically
long and short of it yeah I'm just glad
that Robert Downey Jr came up because he
came a long way from that [__] to be
Iron Man bro yeah this is after Iron Man
Tropic Thunder's afternoon he said on an
interview I had done Iron Man and then
this movie came and I knew it was tricky
but I trusted Ben Stiller something like
I trusted his intention I knew what he
was trying to do yeah so I was like this
could be fun let's do it and he said in
hindsight I think he said something like
in hindsight I know he did Sherlock
Holmes decision but he honest thing he
said I had done the first Iron Man oh
you're right actually came out a few
months after Iron Man oh wow Jesus
Christ Iron Man May 2008 was Iron Man
Tropic Thunder was August 2008. that's
ballsy bro I mean not really if the
movie's already shot and then they
probably were going thinking about
putting Tropic Thunder out until they
saw the success on Iron Man they're like
[__] let's throw this [__] out Robin
Iron Man is they don't know it's gonna
be a mega success yeah yeah also this is
truly pre-cancel culture even though
like you weren't supposed to do
blackface I think it was edgy but people
I think saw what he was trying to do it
no this no no no I lie I lied that right
there is actually black face yeah
because he's pretending to be a black
character but a lot of the stuff that
they said was when I'm lying I was about
to say stuff like Chris Rock when um
Fallon did Chris Rock I don't know if
that was he's pretending to be Chris
Rock so I guess that is blackface I
guess I guess you're referencing the
minstrel show yeah and which is way
different yeah than actually than
actually painting her skin black to look
like a specific black person I don't
think you can win even if he didn't
paint his skin black and still was
pretending to be Chris Rock I think he
still get flat I don't think so you
don't think so I think I don't think so
if he if he like dressed like him and
then did the accents or did the you know
the ACT down and like did all right
Caliendo pretends to be Charles Barkley
people don't he just does the voice I
think I don't think he does the face I
don't think and so people aren't
offended by it yeah it's just like the
like raw history with Minstrel shows
anytime someone puts black on their body
people just tense up and go oh that's
bad even though if it like doesn't
perfectly logically make sense it's just
because it's attached to such a
traumatic history people are just like
don't touch it no I get it even yeah
even though those characters are trying
to make fun of black people in general
right exactly whereas this is
specifically being a black person or
dressing up as Chris Rock as a black
person and dressing up as Kobe and
lookie is a black person when Kimble did
Carl Malone Kimble did Carl Malone but
even with that I was thinking about that
one but it's like yo was he actually
trying to do blackface no he's trying to
calm calm alone you know which which
look there's the distinction like if
you're dressing up as like let's say for
example you do a stereotypical black
person outfit that isn't a person that
we know yeah that to me regardless if
it's back in the day or now you could be
like oh this is blackface you're just
trying to use this an opportunity to
make fun of all the black stereotypes
right yeah but if you're being Chris
rocker you're being Carl Malone or being
something like that you could show that
there is a distinction there because
you're going after one specific person
right that being said anybody triggered
by blackface is going to be triggered by
that as well yeah technically it is
blackface now that I think about it it's
all black yeah it's blackface because
it's a white person pretending to be a
black person that's essentially what the
menstrual show
yeah so if you pretend to be the best
stereotypes of a black person is it
still offensive
depends
depends like if you go as Oprah is it
offensive you're going as a building
if you do 1900 Oprah 1990s Oprah and you
put on like a fat suit you know what I
mean yeah you know you do your hair a
certain way that might come off kind of
like you know you're looking you could
look like you're making fun of her you
know what I mean it just depends what
Oprah and do you have to do the black
skin to be Oprah
um
you know I mean kind of helps yeah I
don't know like is Oprah is open
somebody that's defined by skin color is
there a way to show people that I'm open
like if there's an Asian girl dressing
as Oprah it clears it up if you're a
white girl dressing Zone Pro wait it's
just like a wig yeah you just kind of
look like the nanny I think yeah I guess
you would have to wait
a little Oprah outfit like you'd have to
wear Oprah when she revealed how skinny
she was for the first time yeah with the
black shirt the jeans like people
remember that if you wear JLo's outfit
from the MCV Awards or the Grammys
whatever that one
easy easy absolutely
um
you got to have the wagon with you if
you got the wagon with you and the I
guess that's how much weight she lost in
the wagon exactly so everybody's gonna
know yeah I remember that show they used
to swap the families and that [__] was
crazy crazy Different Strokes
they put white people in blackface yeah
and black people in white face I don't
remember that and then the the wife and
husband they would just Swap and then
live with the other family for like a
week yeah there was a show where they
actually painted like black and white
where like they make the families trade
races and then live in societies of
different races and then reflect on
their experience yeah oh that's the one
I'm thinking about yeah yeah yeah yeah
can I ask you a question and somebody
else is different somebody this I forget
what it was but the conception was
really funny because they're like uh of
course the white people who have the
black face on are like man it's so hard
being black like people look at you
crazy and it's like yeah because they're
looking you walk around the mall in
blackface
walking around and nowadays you got to
think to yourself okay is that like war
paint this person is wearing like what
is this guy about to do yeah
that's what I'm saying
yeah so why do y'all talk so long
I just want to know like I want to know
like for like podcast purposes like what
is it like four and a half hours a day
yeah there's a lot of breaks in between
that like you need a break
what is there like an algorithm thing
like is there a we just we just like
hanging man yeah yeah you know we don't
have children yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know we don't have uh tons of businesses
I'm like what like this is like why
[Laughter]
[Music]
y'all just drop this [__] like two hour
Extravaganza like he's been waiting two
hours to say this two hours no I didn't
realize how long I'm like what the [__]
I'm looking at that clock I'm like is
that how long we've been talking or is
that the time how long have we been
talking about that time wait wait about
an hour 55. damn God damn yo
that is what they're gonna really think
I'm on flagrant now
this is crazy Jesus Christ